майже всіх коридорах по
полетали вікна
Андрій кузніченко кілька разів на
тиждень приходить до свого колишнього
місця роботи першого ліцею Куп'янська
він викладав інформатику і географію
нині допомагає відновлювати будівлю
школу обстріляли росіяни коли залишили
місто у вересні Слава Богу що ці
матеріали хоча б такі матеріали є в
наявності зараз
треба по максимуму
школу
тут Андрій працював до травня навесні
вже під окупацією Але чоловік запевняє
що працював з учнями за української
програмою
спілкувався і так і так і по-русски
по-українськи ми нічого діти діти
навпаки їм більше я кажу Ну як ми будемо
як ми з вами як ми до тебе буде
спілкуватися вони кажуть це Давайте так
давайте давайте українською ми нікому не
скажемо
з вересня окупанти планували розпочати
навчальний процес за власними
стандартами Андрію запропонували
викладати географію але він відмовився
програма не було як такої привезли
підручники їхні тільки-тільки
надруковані перший параграф
підручника за восьмий клас і на третьому
на третьому абзаці написано що ВВП 21
лютого прийняв підписав указ про
визнання так званих
ЛНР ДНР
Я такого не скажу Ну і все і на тому моя
робота і закінчилась активно про
українську позицію каже не висловлював
Це було надто небезпечно за синьо-жовту
стіну в гаражі його рідного брата так
званого окупаційна міліція 10 днів
тримала в ізоляторі колаборантум Андрій
себе не вважає і в українських слідчих
до нього претензії немає Учитель не
отримував зарплату Ані в рублях Ані в
гривнях не їздив на курси в Росію Утім
зізнається у педагогічному колективі не
все так гладко ті хто виїхали не завжди
схвалюють вибір тих хто лишився в
окупації коли
твого близько тобі людину забирають вони
відомому напрямку тримають дуже довго
довго не дають ніяких ніякої можливості
знати вообще живий чи неживий А в нього
двоє дітей а в нього жінка Так і які
можуть бути емоції від кого я це слухати
звинувачення
від свою адресу
важливі Тут життя яке прожив я тут люди
повинні виживати
якщо вони не
плагами не махали на мітинги не ходили
пісні Не співали гімни і все таке інше Я
вважаю що ця людина не є винна у
директорки куп'янської школи-інтернату
Наталії Пушкар інша історія вона 27 днів
провела в ізоляторі Ось цього відділку
за участь у проукраїнському мітингу і
патріотичну позицію тут жінка згадує
найстрашніше коли катували інших людей
це було показово
через стіну у нас біля камер це було
страшно І ці тортури людей за стіною ми
розуміли що це для нас щоб ми це чули
щоб нас залякати І це світло яке
додатково включалося щоб ми не спали
і
не могли ні митися ні чаю навіть собі
нагріти ні води не можна було з крана
пити
окупаційна адміністрація не змогла
призначити нового директора
школи-інтернату колектив вимагав
повернути попередню керівницю тому
врешті Наталю відпустили нині вона разом
з вихователями намагається привести до
ладу свій заклад пошкоджений росіянами
уже після деокупації ось сюди
отака Вирва прилетіла це
зруйнований дах і вікна Це був там у нас
спальний корпус дітки ночували бо в нас
дітки з особливими освітніми потребами
педагоги вберегли чимало цінностей і від
обстрілів і від самих росіян пішли Ольга
Василівна
покажемо наші схрони Лише зараз вони
дістають сховані українські підручники
це воно так стільцями заставлялася і
от ми витягували таку решітку
і
ховали підручники
нічого тут зовсім немає політичного і я
теж не розуміла Чому вони
Саме так знищують українські підручники
Мабуть тому що вони на українській мові
школа-інтернат працювала дистанційно й
до 24 лютого Невдовзі після окупації
заклад почав приймати переселенців тому
окупанти тут не планували починати
навчання від педагогів не вимагали
співпраці з Росією Ми
знали що
їздили там вчителі на курси але Ніхто з
нас не їздив і
навіть ті батьки які намагалися привести
дітей
Ми говорили що не треба тихенько з ними
працювали ховали книжки усе ховали у
військовій адміністрації Куп'янська
кажуть що
25-30% педагогів району співпрацювали з
ворогом чимало з них уже приїхали в
Росію нині у місті тривають перевірки
щодо 20 вчителів тих хто отримував
зарплату в рублях чи їздив на курси в
Росію вважатимуть колаборантами основний
аспект
заробітна плата і пароваліфікація вони
свідомо це робили якщо там лікарі
працюють вони там
давали ще раз кажу цю кляту гіппократа і
вони зобов'язані да Після цієї колядки
надавати допомогу будь-кому
то есть вони не мають права тут є вибір
вони мали співпрацювати
багато вчителів відмовились
співпрацювати і написали заяву на
звільнення згідно з кримінальним
кодексом України колабораціонізмом серед
іншого вважається Пропаганда в закладах
освіти і впровадження освітніх
стандартів держави-агресора передбачено
покарання до трьох років за ґратами такі
справи нині розслідує Служба безпеки
України виконувач обов'язків голови СБУ
Василь малюк заявляв що колаборантами
слідчий вважають учителів які перейшли
на викладання за російською програмою
освітньоюмбудсмен Сергій Горбачов
закликає ретельно розслідувати кожну
справу до його офісу надходять десятки
звернень з окупованих територій У деяких
батьки і педагоги повідомляють що
вчителі йдуть на добровільну співпрацю з
ворогом в інших що звинувачення у
колабораціонізмі недоброзичливці
використовують для зведення рахунків
коли там знаєте якась
Вибачте дурепа біжить наввипередки
багато окупантам це одне а коли людину
під дулом автоматів буквально це не
метафору буквально піддулом автоматів
змушують іти до школи А ми маємо такі
випадки то це вже зовсім інше і тому Я
закликаю всіх людей які
перебувають територіях педагогів для
того щоб не
стати після звільнення звинувачена в
колаборації або визнана колаборації
треба збирати факти примусу факти тиску
на людей щоб це було розглянуто за
даними міністра освіти України Сергія
шкарлета лише 1% учителів на тимчасово
окупованих територіях погодилися на
співпрацю з окупантами очільник мон
запевняє щоб прізвище майже всіх
колаборантів уже відомі Владі